ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
third session of the day here in the
barroom um the next half hour we'll take
a deep dive into the world ofo serving
with zad al- muayed staff engineer at
Adan let's give zad a warm welcome zad
the floor is
yours yeah hi everyone thanks uh for
coming to this talk uh directly before
the lunch so I will try to keep it very
fast uh I appreciate that you are all
here uh um so I'm a Staff engineer at
Adan I work on the ml infra uh teams we
build a lot of the tooling that we use
for uh machine learning kadan and one of
the things we do is the serving stack so
we try to streamline the process for
serving machine learning
models um so we're going to talk today a
little bit around the practices that we
try to enforce uh at addan to ensure
like a reliable and performance setup so
the practices we'll talk about today are
like very generic things so I tried not
to focus on specific Frameworks and uh
like tooling so very generic things that
we can do to have like a reliable and
performance setup but like why do we
talk H so here like I also put Tech
blocks so the if you like to check it's
a Shameless ad for my uh blog's website
so um so yeah so before we talk um we
before we dive in like uh why we're
talking about reliable ml
so like we're doing the transition from
data driven applications to more into
model driven applications so machine
learning is becoming at the heart of a
lot of today's tooling and use cases uh
so back in the days um machine learning
models were usually like recommending
ads doing ads targeting uh recommending
friends for you um these kind of use
cases were a little bit low error
lowcost use cases so if a model would
fail it was okay so if like I'm like
like a vegan shopping online and the
model tells me this is a very nice take
so okay it's it's fine but the one time
this model makes me actually click on
this ad this was a very high reward for
this model so it used to compromise for
the failures this models did so here
like this is an example of like yeah
buying a toaster and saying do you want
the Dark Knight so yeah so um today
these use cases are becoming a little B
more critical with uh machine learning
so to us for example at Adan uh we have
lots of use cases that are powered by ML
and uh some of these use cases are very
critical to all Merchants so for example
a risk model misbehaving on a sale that
a merchant is doing once a year that
they really rely on blocking their
payment suddenly might really take this
Merchant out of business so another
payment like another example like a
payment optimization model doing the
opposite un optimizing payments might
really cause harm and make us lose trust
uh with the clients so this is why
reliability is something we also
optimize for in the envelop steam uh we
don't really only focus on Automation
and decreasing operations but we also
try to make sure the setup is reliable
and
performant
so before I I like go a little bit into
these practices um so I want to talk a
little bit about the scale of our setup
so we serve machine learning in almost
all over the world uh we have like 12
availability zones uh we have lots of
models
online and we have like around 2,400 ml
Services running every day uh we do like
millions of requests and we have like
strict slos for the
latency but it's not only about this so
it's not only about the scale it's a
little bit about the complexity I know
that the slide is too much I couldn't
even fit it all in one slide but like
the setup is a little bit complex and uh
there's like a lot that goes into it so
it's not only about putting services
online there's a lot that also happens
so to the right you have these services
and there's a lot of that and each one
is like a model that you're deploying
but there's also like traffic routing
there's a like there's security there's
authentication there's service Discovery
there's metrics feature lookups
configuration like data scientists also
routing traffic online dynamically so
there's a lot that can happen here we do
automate all of this so there's
operations Wise It's very little but
what I'm trying to illustrate here is
that the setup is complex but it's not
only about the setup how complex it is
it's also like the way how machine
learning works so data scientists are
always changing models and they always
want to try to validate theories so they
only like they always want to try to put
these models as fast as possible online
so there's always like experimentation
is happening online during on production
so we want to make sure the Fire doesn't
start so we're going to talk a little
bit around reliability and a little bit
around performance um in the first part
it will be like few practices that you
can do to have like a reliable setup and
the second part will be a little bit
around
performance so when I talk about
reliability it's like to have a full
tolerance setup uh we want to make sure
our services are available so once you
want to make a prediction the clients
actually can get this prediction and we
want to make sure we have consistent
serving so when I talk about errors or
like
reliable reliability issues I talk about
like two things like technical errors
things can actually like break in your
face so like a service not responding or
like exceptions blowing up but there's
also these kind of errors that sliping
without you noticing so for
example like yeah like a wrong cast on a
type and then the model does something
completely different like from a float
to an end and then a time stamp becomes
like the First of ioi and then so these
kind of issues we'll try to also prevent
them sorry
so
so the practices we try to enforce is
that we want to make sure we have like a
self-contained motra so we want to make
sure things are a little bit more
explicit it's not only that you ship a
model and you put it online but you also
need to include like the minimum
dependencies that the minimum components
that can make sure your
model will be reliable online so we
automate a lot of the processes and
these components help us uh ensure
reliability
online so this like a jar that has not
only your pickles but also like metadata
example requests input output schemas
serving dependencies there's a lot to it
more but I try to this keep it simple
here and only look at the small
components
so we do this to like self-contained
model archives are something that really
helps with
reproducibility so it's easy for us to
reproduce the models and run them like a
different
environments it makes deployments for us
much simpler and we can put them at
different
environments without any external
dependences collaboration becomes easy
so these models can move around they can
be shared to other teammates they can
extend them when they need and this is
becomes like almost
streamlined so so self-contain model
archives have lots of components and the
first one I will talk about is like
super underrated it's actually example
request so this is like like a very
dummy request it's not actually a model
it's like it's like a dummy model um so
this is like here a Json request but
like there were other use cases and
another talk that I so that they can
also package requests like media images
it doesn't really have to be this kind
of request but we need to have an
example request so why do we need it we
needed to streamline the testing and
integration testing uh with the clients
so like you saw in the earlier
slide like the model is never online by
itself there's a client that's always
talking to this model and these versions
are changing very fast so to make sure
clients are
compatible with we use this example
request to do integration
testing but not only about this we have
very strict latency uh requirement so we
can use this example request to stress
test this models and see how they will
perform
online example requests make local
development very easy so not very easy
but you can use them to test your models
easily online uh sorry
locally um we use example request to
also work of services so something that
happens always is like some models have
like slow starts so you put them a
service online or you scale it but then
you see this fluctuations and latencies
because the models need some time to
start warming up so use this example
requests to warm up the
services and also to do health
checks yes so python I think we like
python but uh we all love python but
python typing is not very
um predictable so I put here like an
example
like an example of how typing can lead
to
inconsistencies
so we have like this D model that we
just talked about earlier and it takes
like three parameters it tries to
calculate from monthly salary annual
salary and then there's like this cast
that happens in between and we expect
this model to perform as we expect but
then suddenly the client starts to for
whatever reason send wrong types to this
model and python will just allow this
and things are very
fine so but as you can see like in the
first request when it's actually getting
like this proper and annual monthly
salary the model declines the loan but
in the second second request the salary
is the same the only difference is the
type but the model says here you go so
this is like a very basic
example how types can actually have
incon cause inconsistencies in your
serving um in you're serving online so
you can Implement type
checks by including input output types
you can implement this like any
flamework that you like so like you can
use marshmallow or pentetic or
Panda um but this is something we always
require and it has to be part of the
model and we use this to do pre and post
checks when we put the model online so
for every request we check the input we
check the output we don't really have to
break the request but at least we need
to know what's going
on so another thing we also require are
dependencies I think there was a keyn
note earlier or like a talk that the
only thing she hates is like unpen
dependencies so it's also for us we hate
unpen dependencies um I put an example
here all right yes you can see it so I
put an example here of um so when when
you package a model you have to include
what dependencies are for this model but
you don't only include the dependencies
you have to pin the versions so pinning
the versions is very important because
Small Change in a version of a library
that you depend on can lead to a
completely different transformation
which might lead to a completely
inconsistent setup so I put here an
example I'm not sure if you can read it
but but it's a small change in Panda's
version from 1.35 to 1.40 or 42 can lead
to different return times so in one
place it returns an array sorry in the
original one it returns a string and
then it leads to an array so this is
something that might slip in or might
actually fail online it depends on how
things are
running but definitely something you
don't really
want
so sometimes you put a model but you
don't want to depend on like
dependencies so your model depends on
your repo and you don't want to include
all repo online so we allow you like to
or you can bundle sources with your
model so the point here is that we want
to minimize external dependencies and we
allow you to like package these
dependencies inside the model so the
idea is that the model shouldn't have
external
dependencies and if you don't specify
the sources or if you don't include them
inside the model either as dependencies
with specific versions or inside the
actual artifact what could happen I put
this example here where for example this
my Transformer that your model depends
on might change in the future versions
and then once you unpickle because it's
pickled by reference then you end up
with inconsistencies and then you end up
with completely different
Transformations another thing that might
happen is that this Transformer might be
deleted or renamed and then it's just
going to be an error so
we require that sources are included in
the model if you don't want to put them
as a dependency you can put them as
actually inside the model
or we can also pickle
them and include them inside the model
so either both works and something that
can
help avoid some issues
online so these are very generic and I
talked a little bit about reliability
but we'll talk a little bit more around
performance so performance
so we have we'll talk a little bit about
latency
throughput and a little bit around
memory footprint so ml code can have a
high memory footprint
[Music]
and yeah it's it's not very good you
want to use your resources efficiently
uh you want to be able to scale when you
need you don't know what will happen
when suddenly like a merant suddenly
decides to make a sale on an item that
everybody likes and everybody wants to
shop suddenly and then you have the
spike in traffic so you should be able
to scale when needed also you want to
decrease your memory footprint to also
be able to use your resources
efficiently and also minimize the cost
if not for the cost for the
environment but I think you should do it
so to look at memory footprint like we
always can go back all to the code and
look like what are we really putting
online
so we try to separate serving sources
from training sources so this is like a
very simple thing I think like most of
us use spark or maybe if not spark some
other tool that we use to do like
Transformations or to play with our data
so it's very easy for us to do something
like this where we put like one file
where we have everything inside of it
but this automatically means that online
we will also need all these
dependencies and this increases our
memory footprint automatically increases
our images makes scaling much harder and
inefficient so we advocate for splitting
sources so moving the serving code into
its own
modules then you will only need
dependencies for your serving code
online you don't really need
dependencies that you are not going to
use this automatically brings down the
memory footprint and makes things more
efficient another thing about memory
footprint is python itself so we when we
put our models online we want to do some
sort of parallelism to efficiently use
all our
resources so you probably are going to
package your model in some server put it
online and you want to use your course
efficiently so you don't want to do this
you want to properly use all the cores
and in any language this usually is fine
the more you scale your service in
theory the memory footprint should
remain the same and this is something
like you would
expect in Python also so you're going to
use like some sort of
multiprocessing to efficiently use all
your CES you start adding workers and
you think like the memory footprint is
going to remain the same however in
theory like you will see this with time
so memory footprint will automatically
go up and this is
not like this is not your fault it's
Python's fault so it's a combination of
how python
Works um yeah so it's basically around
like I'm not going to go too much into
details but it's it's basically about
reference counting and like how garbage
collection works so the idea is that
when you start with a single process and
then you Fork these processes the memory
is shared between them all but then
every time you reference an object in
Python it will increment this counters
which are actually mutating the objects
and then copy on right click s then it
moves this object into the other
processes memory So eventually your
memory will be bloated the more you
reference this object the more you
mutate them and eventually you end up
with like times number of workers the
original memory footprint so how can you
think keep things under control there
are few things we can do so for example
we can use shared memory it's not very
straightforward but it works um this
involves a little bit copying of data
into shared memory maybe a little bit
overhead in the
start it lacks synchronization but it
can work uploading your Transformations
and using data sets uh sorry using data
structures that are like numpy data
structures helps a lot um these are
implemented in C which means you're not
really working with python so you don't
really suffer from this issue it's not
very easy to like you can't Implement
everything num Pi so there will be a
little bit some python stuff left so
this will go up but not as much as
possible the third thing is what you can
do is restart your workers often so it's
like a small trick that you can do uh
every X number of requests you can
configure your servers to gracefully
these processes so the memory footprint
will go up but you will keep it under
control so it will not linearly go up I
put some references here I think they
are very nice reads they talk about this
problem uh meta is investing in this
Immortal object that that will hopefully
solve this problem but until then we
have to do these things
so I will talk a little bit about
performance so not really about memory
but more around like
CPU
and yeah so green is good so here like
I'm trying to illustrate like if you run
a multiprocessing uh servers you will
use all your CES and this is something
we'd like to do so we like to keep our
work CPU bound we try to minimize IO
it's a very nice way to reason about um
sorry to reason about performance
because we can very easily calculate the
limitations of our system we can know
how much optimizations are going to
increase performance for us we can do
small like back of the envelope
calculations and we can know what to
expect from our
system however this is not always the
case so this is what you want but
sometimes this is what you get so
you need to make sure you minimize IO
and your workloads so at least this what
we try to do um so here like I added a
single log line and okay like it might
be different based on the codee so here
what you can see is that the cores are
actually doing more system work than
doing the actual work that we want which
automatically brings down the throughput
of our
system so what we try to do is to keep
our work CPU bound we try try to move
away um IO so for example if you're
doing feature lookups moving them into
the client something good here like this
input output scheme is help a lot
because then you can create a contract
with the
clients uh look for logging and kill it
um and then finally like something that
really happens a lot is like this future
warnings so if you if you if you need to
update or if you need to change the
version to mute this warnings it helps a
lot with um
CPU so the last point I will talk about
is uh little bit around daty so I didn't
have like a nice chart to put here so I
took like a dummy chart from our slos
dashboard um so here I'm trying to
illustrate that how we can maintain the
latency so how we can maintain good Asos
for latency and we stay within our
budgets
so there's lots of practices that we can
do but I try to put the generic
stuff
serialization is a problem we want to
minimize it to be doing the actual work
so we can look into fast libraries that
do
serialization compressing request is
something that is useful when you have
like a huge request so when you request
is very big so you don't want to pass it
over all the time over the network the
way it is compressing it sending it over
the network might be faster than
actually sending it as row but the time
it takes to decompress and compress is
less than the time it takes to ship this
over the network so multiply this by
billions of requests and you get a lot
of savings so batch predictions is
something that's also very interesting
um it depends on the framework it might
be hard to implement maybe something
that you can pick up off the shelf um
but it also improves latency a lot
sampling for checks so I talked a little
bit earlier about like schema checks so
something we can do is that we can do
sampling for these checks so we don't
have to do them on every request and
then we minimize the number of checks we
do but we keep our system in good
shape staying up to date on python
versions so for us like we switched from
3.6 to 3.8 I think and then we got like
15 or 20% savings uh improved latency
and then like a bump from 3.8 to 3.11
another 15% multiply this by billions of
requests this is a very very good
savings on time
pandas Tois um minimizing the use of
pandas here so pandas is very generic
it's tries to be very user friendly but
at the same time there's lots of things
that happen that are not necessary
switching to non pies which is a little
bit more uh specific will definitely
improve
latency so this was it for me like uh if
you takeways and I try to keep them
little less is more the less you include
in your models or the less you try to do
the more you actually get in the end
like being explicit about what you
actually package what you actually put
online in the end results in predictable
setups and minimizing external factors
means there's less that you have to
worry about and that's that can go wrong
so thanks everyone for listening and I
hope you enjoyed my
talk